what's up guys we're back here in Miami
it's been a really interesting 48 hours
last video is going absolutely insane so
we're going to be asking people again
what their thoughts are on Andrew Tate
and we'll be on the search for fat G
well I'm sure you guys have heard but
Andrew Tate got freed from prison the
other day so what are your thoughts I
hate him why don't you like him I don't
agree with well I agree with some of the
things he says what do you agree with
um I actually don't remember at the
moment but I don't know I mean I've seen
the majority that I've seen about him is
bad so I don't I really have a lot of
context do you remember any of the stuff
that you didn't like about him or not
really uh very like misogynistic
opinions but I don't remember exactly
his fake social media accounts have been
posting some really interesting things
lately but other than that no comment
like what what kind of stuff just him
pacing around his room that video in
particular again just interesting would
you like a man like top G I mean I
wouldn't I'm right here I wouldn't date
him or be anywhere near him but to each
their own do you have any thoughts on
them or no immediately no it's a quick
no it's a huge red flag why not why
don't you like it's a big red flag no no
no are there any reasons why you don't
like them that you can name
he just comes off as very self-centered
in pompous and again having fake social
media and claiming that you're not on
social media but you're clearly
directing the content that's coming out
about you like
I don't know like oh he claims he
doesn't have his social media then where
is that video why did he take a video of
him pacing around his room what was the
point of that where was that going
you're telling me that he didn't tell
somebody to post that video what Andrew
Tate
you know like the ball the bald guy oh
these guys yeah have you ever seen him
okay uh no I am I don't know it's the
first time when they see this guy I have
another question though what do you
think on feminism I don't support
feminism why not because I think for a
woman it's very important to be with a
man first of all human needs human and
second I was born and raised in country
where women love men's and we respect
them and we want to make their life
happier easier and we love that you know
like we love this feeling to make our
men's happy and here's a big difference
between European or Muslim I'm totally
fine with that cultures but I don't know
why do you think the women here are so
brainwashed and they don't think like
that anymore American ones yeah I think
because they're like too strong and to
be honest they really think that the
American guys are kind of scared of them
I don't know why because there are too
much independent like I can open a door
I can do this and I'm like okay baby you
can you know you're a big fan
why don't you like it because I don't
like what he says about women and women
and how he trade treats women so like
what specifically that you didn't agree
with everything in general he's just
like do you think like your man should
protect and provide for you no you don't
think so no what do you think is your
man's role in the relationship I think a
woman woman should be independent and a
woman is there for herself and the man
should be should respect her and be
there for her support her but not in a
way that she he has to earn the money
and she's there to cook so a woman can
everything do you wanna so you what you
want to work your whole life yeah she
can do everything on her own and a man
should support her in if your man made a
lot more money in you and could support
you would you want that or no and he was
like you guys were totally in love or
that's not ideal for you you want to
work yeah I yeah
okay a lot of guys have a feeling inside
of them that it's your job to protect
and provide for the girls yeah it's just
like what's born inside of guys to be
honest it's like the fire inside of you
does it have to be like this like
forever like a man I don't know I mean
it doesn't have to be like this like
everyone could be gay everyone could be
you know sleeping around with everyone
and then we'll see how you know Society
progresses like that because I mean if
everyone was gay the world would end in
80 years so there are some standards
that you do have to stick by you know so
we can't just change the way the entire
world Works what do you think about
Andrew Tate whatever his name I really
like his message
yeah
Americans enough of these [__]
feminists I need to find fat G all right
Alex where do you think he'd be where
would fat G be right now he's fat G what
do you think he's doing he's probably
bro all right bro we gotta find him bro
he's never eating some [__] food all
right come on we just chucked Chipotle
moxies
bro no [__] way that's him right
there bro that's fat chi bro look at him
he's macking with a girl right now bro
bro fat she got ultimate risk that's
crazy yo let's go over there let's go
over there
bro fat G what are you doing here bro
welcome back dude oh my God you keep
talking with the girls bro yeah it's
having a conversation it's actually one
of the best pizza places on all of like
Florida bro we literally said I was like
where would that GB except for eating
some food right now food bro I just
finished I just had a pie or have you
seen the video since yesterday nah why
what's up bro it's going crazy right now
it's at like 300 000 views everyone
loves you no way I swear to God bro but
there's only one way that we can
actually solidify you as fat G and
actually do that we're going to the
buffet we're going to the buffet dog
dude
it's just a fan on me I got you bro do
you know where there's a buffet around
here
[__]
that would be a detriment but we've been
asking these hoes what they think about
um we've not we've been asking these
nice ladies what they think about Andrew
Tate what my man haven't been they
haven't been a fan today Papa Tate all
right I think we got it I gotta go ahead
and transform you into the fat G and
then go and ask some more people their
thoughts let's do it whatever it is I'm
down
bro
how do you feel yo I'm starting to feel
like a a little bit more than a soldier
y'all guys remember be a soldier and not
a folder stick to what you believe in
and [__] the world dude what's what's
some of like the biggest sauce you'd
give to the young people watching this
then I think you guys need to realize
that the education you're given isn't
always true
story simply means that it's the
Victor's story of what happened so I
would encourage you guys to truly
educate yourself in life anything you
ever told in a history book anything you
ever told period can't be always true
and it's up to you to verify the
knowledge that you receive to put into
your mind it's your mind and nobody
else's but yours verify your information
at all times you know shaving your head
in this this is only one part of
actually becoming fatchy we really need
to see you have some self-improvement
too what do you think about the people
that were saying that you need to hit
the gym and lose this weight and [__]
bro I've been saying I needed to hit the
gym and you know what it's one of those
things where I have to take
accountability for me letting myself
down my whole life and being a fat [__]
you know I choose to go the weak riding
and [__] get fast food all the time
instead of finding a way to cook food
and but you know when you're living your
car man and you're [__] homeless it's
not easy to to make your own food man
you're very dependent off of you know
fast food because of the easy commodity
that it is so
I uh I would like to definitely lose
weight and aspire to be looking like top
G when he came out of [__] prison dog
7417 push-ups I can't even do one dog so
how long have you been homeless for bro
tell me like a little bit more about
your [__] you gave me like a little bit
of a spew yesterday but not too much
yeah so um I actually became homeless
around like the age of 21. uh my mom
kind of kicked me out because instead of
me being a productive man in the family
you know I was just [__] leeching bro
I would literally sit at home all day
and go on the computer and uh my mom got
tired of that bro single mother working
a fast food job ironically she's got
tired of it so she said bro you got a
month if you don't get a job you're out
so I said you know what dude I'll take
that and when I became homeless man my
pers my thought process was I'm gonna
buy a flight ticket from Miami to Austin
Texas because my my thought process was
simple if I stayed homeless in Miami I
was going to be a [__] and I was gonna
cry to Mom be like Mom please take me in
but when I became homeless and I flew to
somewhere I didn't know at all it put me
on a whole different like path man and I
started having to find a place to sleep
a place to survive I had to start making
new contacts what would you say is like
one of the main reasons that you're
still homeless today I guess because as
I I wouldn't say I found comfort in it
but I was very weak-minded where I
thought I was invincible against the
world But when reality kind of hit me
and it made me realize that
you know I wasn't the [__] like I
thought I was I I didn't step out of it
dude when I should have so you know now
that I'm 30 man I've had a whole
different state of mind I've I've been
doing like Street portraits here in uh
Brickell and networking with people man
and now my whole goal at 30 bro is to
get off the streets fix my teeth fix my
body like get healthy and and continue
to network with people man like I want
to be that [__] guy in Miami that
people know everybody like I'm the mayor
or some [__] did Andrew Tate really
helped change your mind on a lot of this
stuff yeah man I started watching Andrew
burn I started to take a lot of
self-accountability and realize that I
was the [__] up the whole time and it
never was the world but it was myself
damn so for the longest time you weren't
taking ultimate self-accountability you
were blaming stuff on other people that
was kind of your excuse for where you
were in life yeah I wouldn't say the
world but I was I wouldn't say the
people but I was blaming the world but
you know growing up and realizing how
much fatter I got and how much more it
was my fault that I was the one putting
this food in my [__] mouth dude it
wasn't anybody else but myself how many
buffets have you put out of business yo
um to this day around 64 is my record 64
buffets put out of business yeah all
types of Buffets Japanese Chinese
uh anything Doug people stopped inviting
me to family meals bro because they were
like bro we gotta [__] cook twice to
get Mom for this guy
yo why you laughing bro I got shunts
from my own family for eating a lot bro
I'm literally shaving your head with the
same razor I shave my balls with bro bro
I've had worse situations yo do you want
to see how good I used to look from
handsome G
totally [__] different guy and that's
the guy I let down bro that's the guy
I'm gonna be again yo guys give this
video 5 000 likes and we'll shave the
cameraman's head too
oh my God I see myself in the reflection
dude dude is it all off yeah bro I've
never been bald I did one time I shaved
my head like in solidarity with my aunt
who had cancer and but I haven't seen
myself like this in a long time dude
it's weird
ladies how you doing you want to have
some Bingo nights tonight
tonight
I don't think they like the baldness bro
yo you think you might have [__] me up
here dude no bro I got you right don't
worry
yo somebody's calling me
yo
yo yo pearly things is calling me dude
get the [__] Eddie hug this no way bro
hello
yeah it's me fat G what's up
how do you know about me
yo she saw the video or something dude
she said she saw the video like 15
minutes ago I knew she was subscribe
oh my actually dude that's [__] crazy
damn pearly do you mind if like we chat
for like five minutes
dude I'll be right back dog all right
I'm gonna go talk to him huh go clean up
a little bit [__] that I got pearly on
the phone dog
I guess he's officially fat Gina you
just saw fetchy he told his story I mean
it really is pretty insane and I think
we all really want to see him have as
much success as possible in the future
on his self-improvement journey so I'm
gonna pop up his venmo right here I've
already sent him a little bit of money
just to help him out
um so if you guys want to send him any
money at all I'm sure he would greatly
appreciate it and in the next video I'll
make sure to shout out some of you guys
that actually donate to him I'll make
sure to check in with him and Shout some
of you out but yeah let's get back to it
I'm sure you guys heard but Andrew Tate
just got released from prison like two
days ago so what are your thoughts I
think we should leave him in prison why
he gives sexual predator vibes so if
someone gives sexual predator Vibes we
should just throw them in jail what kind
of vibe does he give that sexual
predator I mean he was put in prison for
a reason well they just let him out
because they didn't have any evidence
they were looking for evidence while he
was locked up doesn't that just mean he
has a good lawyer no if anything it's
the opposite because he was in there for
three months with no evidence imagine
they just locked you up and for three
months they were like we gotta look for
something on what's your name you don't
have to say your name but that's crazy
is there anything he said specifically
that you didn't like I mean the whole
like
sexual workers thing so like on do you
think like people that do only fans
management should go to jail no but
that's by choice so so we're his girls
he paid them all like a percentage I
mean if you think about the Jeffrey
Epstein girls were willing too well
those were those are underage girls
I don't know that's I I don't think
comparing Jeffrey up to these Island to
doing only fans is the same thing I'm
glad I'm glad any man got out of jail
man
[Music]
no man deserved to be in jail like
unless he did something crazy you know
I'm saying like that she like did some
like pedo [__] or there's some like rape
sales some crazy [__] then that's
different but like other than that man
if you selling weed are you doing some
other [__] man like I'm saying like the
laws they flip-flops so you know what
I'm saying like
I don't know like at the end of the day
if you ain't doing all crazy man they
ain't you don't belong in there but like
I ain't gonna lie before Andrew take
this [__] man I'm [__] with the message
you pushing this [__] so like you know
what I'm saying yeah I'm glad I'm glad
he out you know what I'm saying so what
are your thoughts mine are a little
controversial but you look like you like
them I mean I mean I agree with some of
the things he said but I definitely know
he knows bad things he said
certain things about women that sounds
kind of bad I know but like he's talked
about how men should pay for everything
and I agree what did you disagree with I
don't know maybe like I've heard some
bad things about him but I don't know if
it's true or not like something about
him and like sex scandal or something
like yeah that was all just false what
do you think about him you look like you
don't look like you're like I really
know I'm not very educated on Andrew
Tate but I don't really agree with him I
didn't even know he was in prison
honestly yeah what stuff do you disagree
with that he said um enjoy the way he
talks about women and like I agree with
like the paying for stuff like for the
most part but he's I don't know I don't
think he's a very good influence on our
youth anything specific other than the
pain no I just don't really like him
okay I get that all right
yo what veggies thank you
[Music]
I'm here bro I heard you talk about tape
man that's why you don't like 5G
I'm sorry top G I got confused on myself
what don't you like about how he speaks
about women this is patchy by the way
I'm a local guy out here
um
I just think he's like got a lot to say
and it's kind of harmful to a lot of
young people
you don't know what he said that's
harmful he can't like give you like
specific uh
yeah or I'd get myself incorrect what if
I told you that anything you heard is
wrong because he's actually said that
women are beautiful creatures and
without them there's no life that he
says we must protect them at all costs
and that's actually what Andrew Tate
teaches us he wants us to be more
masculine so we could be better husbands
better I like how he describes women the
way that he said they should be actually
this is gonna sound bad well he's talked
about like how he wants a woman that's
like feminine and girly and he wants to
be masculine and honestly I I don't I
would never force that on anyone else
but I would like that why do you think
so many like it's like bad to say that
like if I say I want a feminine girl I'm
looked at like a demon why do you think
that is it's personal preference I'm
saying I don't care what other people do
but for me I want to be feminine girly
and I want a masculine man
well perfect for each other
we actually support women like that
and that there's actually a difference
in a role for themselves as well as
ourselves
honestly that's what I want I want
old-fashioned like do you have any crazy
experiences on psychedelics or anything
yeah dude I was recently at a music
festival here in Miami during my uh
Miami March uh music week and I started
talking to like this group of people and
I was like yo I kind of wish I got some
like M M's right now I was craving it
like yo we got chocolate I was like [__]
it dude so I took the chocolate and I
started [__] videos I was like
tripping like an hour and a half later
and I'm [__] dancing because I
actually dance believe it or not fat G
moves bro I just I just started seeing
[__] like gay guys everywhere bro and
it was weird like [__] shirtless
naked we're not naked but like shirtless
gay guys everywhere I'm [__] dancing
dude I'm like [__] having a good time
and then like the DJ hit like a light
and I woke like I opened my eyes I'm
like what the [__] I'm literally
surrounded by like gay guys everywhere
in the crowd and I'm like I gotta get
the [__] out of here so I turned I
started walking at [__] another gay
guy over there shirtless I'm like what
the [__] going on bro it got so bad I
started looking through the whole
Crawford tits dude I'm like I gotta look
at tits dude and I [__] finally found
a pair of tits I'm like oh sanity and
then I had to keep making my way through
the crowd dude but it was like I know it
sounds funny but dude it's scary bro
because when you're tripping and then
you start to like just see forget you
yeah bro it [__] with your head and I'm
tripping hard and I'm like what the [__]
dude I have to look for tits anywhere I
could find them dude and I [__] just
kept Scavenging you I'm like yo that's
checkpoint a and I go to the tits and
I'm like next pair of tits oh [__] more
gay guys dude [__] I have to get out
of there dog the [__] was trippy as [__]
I see y'all here you know you're trying
to do your thing
um I want to go and support you thank
you and I have a little I have something
left over from the strip club the other
day so no way it's not yours get a
haircut
get the [__] out of here dude you're
good bro I did a good job with his hair
bro can I give you a hug bro thank you
go ahead you're good bro bro get a new
outfit get whatever you need dude I'm
gonna help you bro I like you a lot bro
I want to say something man Adam has
been one of the coolest [__] guys
that I've met out here and on a genuine
note look I'm gonna take the glass off
for no character this guy actually
[__] spoke to me dude he gave me a
chance he gave me his number we started
conversating this guy actually wanted to
help me with my position in life and
like I appreciate this man for real
because if you have no idea like I'm not
trying to be like oh sob story but dog I
have literally no friends I'm a lone
wolf so when I come across people have
like a high quality calibrates
themselves bro I want to have those
people in my life and like Adam's Lee
one of those people dog that I want to
help him out to the best of my abilities
no matter what it is bro and I'm honored
bro that I really have met you and and
meeting you bro is a true blessing bro
and I hope in the future I can help you
reach lens way above the skies bro man
look I said to myself I'd rather give it
to you than throw it on stripper so
thank you bro got it double it and give
it to somebody else yeah how am I gonna
double it
um I don't know put it in your butt I'm
gonna put in my
we'll get ready dude okay what do I need
to do
a question for an interview sure
have you heard of Andrew tape before
yeah what do you what are your thoughts
on entertain getting released
um from the Russia
um I think people think he's a little
more controversial than he needs to be
yeah misunderstood yeah exactly what are
your thoughts on them do you like his
takes and stuff his steaks his takes
like his points of view um I don't know
that much but I'm a republican very
beautiful okay moderate see ya
abortion's great
what's wrong with you no are you [__]
kidding me are you [__] kidding me
are you kidding me no I'm absolutely
[__] right are you telling me
abortion's great
I'm saying okay wait let's I don't mind
can you repeat what you said I didn't
mean abortion is great okay but I'm
saying
are you gonna tell me that as a woman
that abortion is not my right how
[__] yeah so as a father I have no
saying what my child should be born or
not it's your choice solely yeah because
as a mother if I don't have the keyword
you're only a mother child you're only a
mother if you choose to have a child
wait wait wait no no no are you
listening are you gonna listen to me
I'll listen to you but I'm gonna let you
know right now I'm not gonna be no
[__] [__] ass Jack I'll tell you
straight up you're gonna listen to me
what I'm telling you right now as a
mother
I can make a choice if my kid should be
here or not
what because if I need to have a child
my kid has a choice to be here or not
and as a mother a kid has a choice to be
here or not but you're taking that Kid's
Choice Away by [__] killing them no
you just said that Julie just said that
as a mother I have the right to choose
on my kids here now but the kid doesn't
choose no no I'm speaking we're having a
conversation we are but I'm speaking
[Music]
I should have a choice
to say hey my kid should be here or it
should not be here and as a father I
also should have a choice in that part
that's true but I'm just saying like my
kid should be here or should not be here
and I'm just my kid too and I would
choose if my child should be here or not
because at the end day I'm the one
supporting that a lot of fathers don't
well unfortunately that's why you
choosing the wrong man
at least you found fetchy
it's true but anyway long story very
short as a mother okay you have a choice
to make sure your kid is here or not
yeah and so as a father what I recommend
to you is you find yourself a
conservative man who knows what he
should do and that will step up and
actually do what needed to be done as a
father to make sure that you and your
child our child hypothetically are taken
care of and live a prosperous great life
I just have one question so like you
mentioned you're conservative but like
why is abortion the one thing that you
came out and like that you wanted to
defend that's a thing
no I know but it's just interesting
because I feel like a lot of people
aren't pro-choice they're pro-abortion
nowadays it's kind of it's just kind of
interesting this is pro-abortion no it's
not a lot of a lot of people are like
advocating for abortions and other
people getting I'm really [__] drunk
and I cannot give you my whole [__]
real choice right now
but no yeah right here I'm gonna I'm
gonna hook you guys up and you guys are
gonna get married hard pass from [__]
fat G I don't want women like that what
the fart is your [__] problem right
now
you're [__] delusional
yes you're delusional shuttle said
delusional women dog they're making the
world the worst place every day excuse
me boss do you want to answer a quick
question
no
do you know who entertain is
okay have a good one bro
bro bro I'm gonna go I'm gonna go hold
square I'm gonna go square and he's
gonna give me a mission
so the reason I know a little bit of
Arabic and I'm like
a little bit well versed on like the
Islamic faith is because when I was a
kid believe it or not I'm originally
from New Jersey
and uh I was in third grade when 9 11
happened after 9 11 bro I'm not even
lying to you all the Muslim kids
disappeared from the [__] schools bro
really yeah they stopped coming to
school a bunch of kids that I knew that
were Egyptian from a whole different
parts bro they just disappeared and that
never came back because the world has
such a hate for his uh for Muslim people
it was crazy bro but I grew up around a
lot of Muslim people I worked for them
and everything it's crazy because they
really are like some of the nicest
people you'll meet super super nice
people man I'm talking about like so
nice so literally invite you to your
house anyone know you'll invite you for
dinner they'll make sure you're okay
super nice people bro super nice people
but unfortunately they have such a bad
rep because society and government push
it into your mind to make you think that
they're the enemies when in reality
America
can't say that on YouTube you know
what'd you say he's like he's like it's
like a henchman oh
what are your thoughts on feminism what
I tell a lot of things but the two I
don't know how I don't know how to say
it in English you speak Spanish you
sound like I do I speak Spanish
business
I'm gonna tell you one thing can you see
my chest well this night smoking this
cigar with the fat G effect Doug move
the mic real quick can you see this
dude I told you bro the muscles are
starting to get out dude he's a jiggling
yeah bro [__] Jiggles dog hey ask her go
to dance I bet you all she knows how to
dance nowadays twerk bro fetchy I gotta
say something if you slim some pounds
down like get get your get your [__]
going straight bro [__] gonna be all
over you bro imma be like Yo Ma I heard
you were looking for a dancer yes yes I
am be like yo you ever seen a man move
so Swift she's gonna be like nah I'll be
like yo I'm gonna show you real quick yo
it's your lucky night baby
oh baby
sorry bro I got excited bam you got some
moves oh yeah dude you want to know
something funny I've actually been on
two Spanish uh TV shows for my dance
from bro do you have like the clips yeah
we're popping that up right now
if we get 25
000 likes on this video I will literally
sign up for a gym membership I'll pay
for it I'll pay for it I want to earn my
way through life you know what I mean so
I'm gonna pay for it and I'm gonna go to
the gym and that's what I'm gonna do 25
000 likes I'll sign up for the gym by
next year if I don't lose a pound you
got to pay for the membership dog I want
to personally thank everybody who's
reached out to me with all the love and
the kindness a lot of a lot of people
have actually reached out offering to
send me money to help me out and I want
to tell you one thing don't send me no
money and this is why I want you guys to
take that money and I want you to go to
people in your own community and I want
you to build your people up I'm a random
guy out here I'm gonna do whatever I
have to do to network and make my way
out of this homeless position to where I
want to be in life so let me do that but
you guys who have offered to send me
money to help me and all that stuff
listen we all have a message and a
purpose to do all right we're in an era
in life where unfortunately we have a
lot of bad agendas going on and what we
need to all do globally is stand up and
be the man that we want to be in life so
help your people will take care of
people if you see somebody homeless or
somebody you see that struggling maybe a
friend a family member whatever take
care of them help your own people out
before you help me out okay because
that's the only way we can get any word
up but we can build our own community
and we can help our people get up in
life we'll go anywhere from there we
need to make our people soldiers all
right so I'm gonna end this by saying
okay always be a soldier never be a
folder stick to your values and commit
to your values because guess what life
will be so much more beautiful if you do
that so I just wanted to say that man
fat [__] G fat [__] G
sorry bro that's horrible
yeah
fat G out I'm on a diet gonna go have
some salads
[Music]